la convención constitucional chilena
iniciará este 15 de febrero la primera
sesión plenaria para la discusión y
votación de los artículos del texto de
lo que será la nueva carta magna el
órgano encargado que cuenta con 155
miembros distribuidos en siete
comisiones se conformó en julio de 2021
este deberá presentar los informes con
los principales artículos que plantea
para que una propuesta pase al pleno
deberá contar con dos tercios de los
votos es decir 103 al menos en términos
de derechos sociales yo creo que va a
haber valido la pena todo este esfuerzo
yo creo que hay mucho consenso en las
cosas básicas que originaron o detonaron
al final de la
crisis social el estallido de la
revuelta no sé como quieran decirle que
vamos a avanzar la convención
constitucional deberá tener para julio
de 2022 la propuesta final de la nueva
constitución posteriormente el documento
tendrá que ser ratificado a través de un
plebiscito obligatorio entendemos que
ésta no va a ser una contestación
maximalista pero si pensamos que
claramente es el escenario del mayor
debate político que estamos teniendo hoy
día donde por primera vez existe una
verdadera posibilidad de participación y
de expresión popular este proceso
constituyente surgió para aplacar la
crisis social de 2019 que se prolongó
por más de un año que inició con masivas
protestas en todo el territorio del país
sureño en octubre de 2020 el 80 por
ciento de los chilenos votó a favor de
que se redacte una nueva constitución
para que reemplace al aprobada durante
la dictadura de augusto pinochet